- [Voiceover] What number is shown
by the place value blocks?
So here we have several
sets of place value blocks,
some with many many many blocks
and some with just single blocks
stacked on top of each
other, and we want to know
what number is represented bay
all of the blocks combined.
So let's start over here
with the single blocks
stacked on top of each other because
it will be the easiest one to count.
We can zoom in on that a little bit,
make it easier for us to count,
and these are just single blocks, ones,
stacked on top of each
other, so we can count them,
and we'll see there's one,
two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine blocks.
Nine blocks right here, then moving over,
now we have columns of ones,
and each of these columns,
here's nine because nine is
even with this other nine column
plus one more is 10, so
each of these columns
has 10 blocks, these are tens.
How many tens do we
have, we have one, two,
three, four, five, five sets of 10,
or 50, so we have 50 blocks here plus
nine more in that last column.
Moving over, now we have
these columns of 10,
but it's several columns
of 10 stuck together
to make sort of like a slab.
How many columns of 10 are in this slab?
There's one, two, three, four, five, six,
seven, eight, nine 10 columns of 10.
10 rows of 10 or 10 columns of 10,
which is a total of 100, so
each of these slabs is 100,
and how many slabs do we have?
We have one, and then two,
a second one back there.
So we have two hundreds, or 200,
and then finally, scooching
it over a little bit,
here we have these slabs of 100,
these sets of 100, all stacked together,
so there's one set of 100 here,
then another set behind
it, and another, and so on.
So let's count how many hundreds this is.
We have 100, 200, 300, 400,
500, 600, 700, 800, 900,
and that last one makes it 1,000,
so these are thousands, and
how many thousands are there?
There are one, two, so 2,000.
Two thousands, zooming
back out, we can look
at all of the amounts we had.
We had 2,000 blocks plus 200 more blocks
plus 50 more blocks plus nine blocks,
or in total we have 2,259 blocks.
Moving on to this next one, we know
what these different sizes represent.
Here this column at the end is ones.
Right beside it, these are columns of 10.
We know those are tens, then we don't have
any of the hundreds,
any of the where we had
10 sets of 10 making
sort of like a flat slab,
we don't have any hundreds in this number,
but we do have these large cubes
made up of many many many small cubes,
and those are thousands, because
they were 10 sets of 100.
So now let's count, we
have one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight, ones,
which is the same as eight,
plus one, two, three tens, 30,
plus no hundreds again, but one, two,
three thousands, which is 3,000.
So when we combine these numbers,
we need to be careful to
remember there are no hundreds.
Our number will be three
thousand, zero hundreds, and 38.
3,038 is the number represented
by these place value blocks.
For this one, I encourage
you to pause the video
and see if you can figure out on your own
what number is represented
by the place value blocks.
And now we can look at it together.
Let's remember, this is ones,
tens, hundreds, and thousands.
So looking at our ones, we have
one, two, three, four ones.
Four ones plus one, two tens, which is 20,
10 plus 10 is 20, plus now these hundreds.
There's several hundreds, let's see,
100, 200, 300, 400, 500,
600, seven hundreds.
There's seven of the hundreds plus
only one of the thousands,
which will be 1,000.
And now to combine this,
to write this all together,
this will be 1,724 is the number shown
with these place value blocks.